[Music]
one of the things la gets a bad rap for
all the vanity license plates people
have in this town yeah it's kind of a
thing it's famous in LA people like to
brag with their vanity license plates
right we saw this one the other day look
at it says 5k a day so either this guy
runs a 5k every day or he earns $5,000 a
day either way he's bragging it's this
very maybe both yeah yeah la think yeah
yeah drive around like check me out a
load of me
get a load of me yeah you know so I just
wanted to point out to be fair to Los
Angeles that a lot of people in this
town are very humble a lot of Los
Angelenos are very humble people and we
wanted to prove it we went out and we
photographed a bunch of their humbler
license plate right yeah they have a
humble sensibility let's check them out
like we saw this one and it says hair
plugs good we saw this one IQ 73 oh boy
bragging he'll get this one still Faxon
that's cute yeah I saw this one just one
DUI this one where depends yeah then
look at this one I'm a 5
then this one not bragging at all Tom
Arnold's mistress had to go to the
smaller font yeah exactly I can't
believe that's a legal plate what it is
look at this one 1.9 GPA let them know
yeah hope someone on the staff has this
one look at I suck look at this one
right here have three friends that's a
lot
yeah and finally there's mine look at
that cable hose
[Music]
for the cable home I'm cable host and
also I suck yeah those are my two cars